the golden feature construction is the
construct already potential roles of
features a bad passions in order to
predict the target outcome
next who wants to introduce fell key concepts
de relay de the feature construction
first european in detail bing is it en
sequences over time
diagnos estate is the  dating the target off
can haven't
in the heart failure predictive modeling
the sample
something patients diagnosed with heart
failure an estate
since control patients to hartfield
agneessens in series
week and un idea of control pension is
the day still
we commonly used to use the  heart
failure homeless cities de match and kees
patients diagnosed time for the
corresponding control
wie voor de dijk nose day we have time
window
cabbage production window
die for the preaching window we have
the index thee and which we would use the
line predictive models to make up
production debate the target came down
before the index 2 we have another
time windows.old alteration window
wie z  all the pc information happening the
ring so alteration window to construct
features
the window and idea of i read a street
for instance we can count the number of
times and event ports
for a sample of time to die your baby's
code have a 3 times during  the soldier
party window
the corresponding feature for time to do
a baby sequels 3
or sometimes week in t coverage of the
evil value
for apple in pension s2 epg onesie
measures the ring oxidation window
week in theory jordy's to measure mens
is a feature for aids baby  onesie
de length prediction window and
observation window
arthur important parameters de going to
a pak de modder performance
here's another example illustrating the
impact of production window
in discharge de lexus is the accuracy of
the mobile
de hired a better
the witch xyz is the sites on the  production
window
which varies from zero-day is the nine
hundred days
we can see the accuracy of the model
drops is wie en grace de produ  ction
window
because it's easier for
predicting in the future dancing shovel
for into the future
next wie ilustrator impact using some
examples
nou let's consider the performance of
the graduation windows
typically is da crisis
de performance impulse pikachu no more
but the patient sd observations  window
a crisis